>> Joey: WELCOME BACK.
THE SO CALLED TOLERANT LEFT
SHOWING TRUE COLORS.
THE LOCAL MOB LASHING OUT AT
STARS SYDNEY SWEENEY TELLING HER
SHE HAS A RACIST AFTER POSTING
PHOTOS FROM HER MOM'S 60TH
BIRTHDAY PARTY.
SO WHAT WAS THE CONTROVERSY?
AN ATTENDEE WAS WEARING AND
PLEASE BRACE YOURSELVES HERE, A
BLUE LIVES MATTER T-SHIRT.
OH, THE WORD.
AND ANOTHER SHOWS A GUESS
SHOWING MAGA SAYING MAKE 60
GREAT AGAIN.
IN THE UPCOMING ACTRESS FIGHTING
BACK, YOU GUYS, THIS IS WILD"
PURITY CELEBRATION FOR MY MOM'S
MILESTONE 60TH BIRTHDAY HAS
TURNED INTO TO OBSERVED
POLITICAL STATEMENT WHICH WAS
NOT THE INTENTION.
PLEASE STOP MAKING ASSUMPTIONS.
WHAT SHE MEANS, JIMMY PLEASE
STOP ASSUMING -- THIS WOMAN IS
AS CONSERVATIVE AS
HILLARY CLINTON.
SHE WORKS MIDDLE HOLLYWOOD AND
SHE'S NOT CONSERVATIVE AND SHE
TWEETED BLACK LIVES MATTER A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
SHE IS BEING SHAMED FOR LOVING
HER FAMILY.
>> WHAT SHE NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND,
SHE SHOULDN'T HAVE TOUCHED THIS
BECAUSE IT AMPLIFIES IT AND
GIVES IT WHAT IT WANTS.
THERE WAS A COLLEGE INDUSTRY OF
PEOPLE GETTING OUT OF OUT OF BED
TO GET MATT ON TWITTER.
SCIENTISTS HAVE A WORD FOR THEM
AND THEY ARE CALLED LOSERS.
SHE GAVE LOSERS A LOT OF OXYGEN
BECAUSE THEY CAN RUN WITH THE
STORY.
THE TRUTH IS EVERYBODY IF YOU
WERE EAVESDROPPING ON SOMEBODY'S
PARTY LOOKING TO TRASH THEM
BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT GETTING
INVITED TO THE PARTY.
THESE ARE LOSERS.
>> Joey: SAY IT AGAIN THEY ARE
CALLED WHAT?
WHAT?
>> LISTEN TO ME.
YOU WILL NEVER BE AT A PARTY AND
I CAN'T WAIT FOR THE GUY THAT
GETS OFFENDED THAT EVERYTHING
SHOWS UP HERE THAT IS THE POINT.
YOU CANNOT CATER TO THESE PEOPLE
IN SOCIETY BECAUSE THEY ARE THE
WORST AMONG US.
WE NEVER LIKED THEM ON
SOCIAL MEDIA AND WE SHOULD NOT
PANDER TO THEM NOW.
SHE SHOULD HAVE TAKEN AN
INSTAGRAM PHOTO THAT SAID MAKE
THE MIDDLE FINGER GREAT AGAIN.
>> Joey: I CAN KIND OF
SYMPATHIZE, SHE WANTS A CAREER
AND SHE'S GOOD AT IT AT IT
EVIDENTLY.
IN THIS SHOW ABOUT BEING
INCREDIBLY HAPPY.
SO YOU KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT WHEN I SAY, THERE ARE
ACTORS IN HOLLYWOOD BIG-NAME
ACTORS WHO WILL SEND ME A
PICTURE OF FOX IN THE GREEN
ROOM, BUT THEY WOULDN'T TOUCH
BEING ON FOX WITH A 10-FOOT POLE
BECAUSE THEY ARE SCARED
APPEARANCE BEFORE ONE OF THOSE
THINGS, JOEY, THEY WON'T CALL
YOU BUT THEY WILL CALL YOU TO
SAY HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
BECAUSE THAT WOULD TAINT THEM.
AND I WOULD IMAGINE THAT
PROBABLY HER INSTINCTS, BUT I
BET HER AGENT HAD SAID, YOU ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO ADDRESS THIS
BECAUSE WE WILL NOT GET ROLES."
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND CRISIS
COMMUNICATION.
RESISTANCE TWITTER IS THE WORST
PEOPLE IN THE WORLD.
IF HE WILL IGNORE THEM, THEY GO
AWAY.
>> Joey: YOU KNOW, HE ROLLED
WE TALK ABOUT SOCIALIZING BUT
YOU SPEND TIME WITH THESE CRAZY
PEOPLE THAT I CALL
PROGRESSIVE'S.
[LAUGHTER]
SO YOU KNOW A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
HOW THEY THINK.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT BUT WHAT
IS THE THOUGHT PROCESS?
I WILL ASK YOU THIS, IS BLUE
LIVES MATTER T-SHIRT RACIST?
>> Harold: BY NO MEANS.
>> Joey: IS DONALD TRUMP
RACIST?
>> WE HAVE A T-SHIRT THAT SAYS
FUN FBI.
SO PEOPLE -- LOOK THIS IS
ABSURD.
ABSOLUTELY ABSURD.
I DON'T CARE WHAT THESE PEOPLE
ARE WEARING T-SHIRTS OR HATS
THAT THEY ESPOUSE THEIR
POLITICAL PARTY.
WE ARE AMERICANS.
FOR THOSE OF US THAT BELIEVE IN
FREEDOM, FREEDOM EXTENDS THOSE
OF MY PARTY WHO BELIEVED DEEPLY
IN PRO-CHOICE AND THOSE WHO
BELIEVE DEEPLY IN BEING ABLE TO
DO THINGS BEHIND CLOSED DOORS IN
YOUR HOME.
HOW ON EARTH CAN YOU TAKE THIS
YOUNG LADY ON WHO LIKELY AGREES
WITH A LOT OF THE PEOPLE?
>> Joey: EXACTLY.
>> Harold: BUT EVEN IF SHE
DIDN'T, IT IS HER PARTY.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO HER MOM.
>> Joey: JUDGE...
>> Harold: WHO CARES.
IT IS HER PARTY.
>> Joey: JUDGE, YOU ARE KNOWN
FOR EXUBERANT SOCIAL PARTY.
HOW WOULD YOU REACT IF SOMEBODY
LIKE HILLARY CLINTON SHOWED UP
TO ONE OF YOUR PARTY'S?
IS THIS HOW CONSERVATIVES WOULD
REACT?
>> Judge Jeanine: NO ONE WOULD
CARE, FIRST OF ALL.
BUT I HAVE TO TELL YOU WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT P.R. PEOPLE HER P.R.
PEOPLE, SOME P.R.
SHE IS A MEMBER OF I DON'T KNOW
SOME AGENCY.
AND THE A IN THE NETWORK, THE
PERSON FROM THE NETWORK SAID
YOUR
FANS, POSTING PHOTOS OF YOU
WITH YOUR DAD AND BLUE LIVES
MATTER SHIRT IS AN UNREASONABLE
EARLY.
THEY ARE RELATE -- THIS P.R.
PERSON FROM THE NETWORK IS
REALLY HITTING IT.
THIS IS WHAT I THINK.
IF YOU ARE OFFENDED BY SOMEONE
WHO WEARS A BLUE LIVES MATTER
T-SHIRT, WHY DON'T YOU SEND A
LETTER TO YOUR LOCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND TOLD HIM IF I
CALL YOU FOR 911, DON'T SHOW UP
BECAUSE I NO LONGER WANT TO BE
ASSOCIATED WITH YOU.
THESE PEOPLE ARE SO STUPID.
IT AMAZES ME.
>> Joey: 100% RIGHT AND THIS
IS THE ONE COMMENT, ONE OF THE
PEOPLE RESPONDED WITH THAT MAKE
AMERICA 60 AGAIN HAVE TO IS
VIOLENCE.
LET ME TELL YOU, HAVE YOU EVER
BEEN PUNCHED IN THE FACE YOU
NEVER WALK AWAY THINKING
THANK GOD THAT WAS NOT